Команда Зеленського проти мера Кличка. Новий раунд.
Спершу упродовж місяця правоохоронці і прокурори проводили обшуки,
вилучали документи на комунальних підприємствах, підпорядкованих КМДА,
навіть у заступників Кличка, натякаючи на викриття корупційних схем.
А кульмінацією стала поява спецпризначенців біля квартири мера столиці 18 травня.
Кличко розцінює це чергову спробу усунути його з посади голови КМДА,
яку він наразі автоматично займає як міській голова.
Проте міська прокуратура Києва говорить мовою зібраних нею фактів
і повідомляє про масштабну роботу з викриття корупційних схем заволодіння коштами
столичного та державного бюджетів.
За результатами слідчих дій у комунальних підприємствах Києва
вручено підозру 11 особам, в тому числі чиновникам КМДА.
Ідеться про розкрадання коштів на суму понад 40 млн гривень.
Кличко та його заступники натомість заявляють,
що прокурори та слідчі маніпулюють фактами.
Коли обшук проводиться в одному місці, і упротоколі
зазначено, що не вилучено нічого,
але публікуються інші фотоз інших місць обшуку.
Будемо на це реагувати.
Станом на сьогодні у жодного з представників київської міськради,  виконавчого органу
та комунальних підприємств грошові кошти, які фігурували на фото, не вилучені.
Кличко та його команда вважають, що акція правоохоронців
спрямована на те, щоб облити "брудом" керівництво мерії.
Мовляв, з корупцією вона бореться: з 2015-того року
регулярно надсилали правоохоронним органам
матеріали аудитів і повідомляли про виявлені порушення.
З того, що було надіслано, тільки 168 були продовжені
в якості кримінальних проваджень.
Той дискурс, в якому ми живемо останні півтора тижні,
говорить про те, що  саме за цими кримінальними провадженнями
в останні півтора тижні почалися певні слідчі дії.
Це не може не викликати питань…
Багато питань і у містян до ситуації довкола мерії:
Моя думка, що це повинен вирішити суд.
Є за що? Чому не раніше, а зараз?
Чому в такий манері? Відволікти від якихось інших питань?
Любов народу призводить до заздрості. Хтось йому заздрить.
Кличко- нормальна людина! Головне, гроші чесно заробив
в бою, як боєць справжній!
Це спроба захоплення влади "зеленими".
Кличко - нормальний мер для Києва. Найкращій з тих, що були.
За що переслідують? Мабуть, через незаконні дії були в нього.
Наприклад, сьогодні комісія із земельних питань,
абсолютно незаконно виділили ділянку на Грушевського.
Без конкурсу і тендеру.
Я вважаю, що це політика - політична компанія.
Бажання притиснути політичного опонента на майбутніх президентських виборах.
У партії Зеленського "Слуга народу" відкидають
політичну мотивацію обшуків та будь-який тиск на слідство.
Це в нас така політична традиціяв країні, коли хтось у щось вляпався,
то відразу починають розповідати, що це політичний тиск.
Це діяльність правоохоронних органів. Вони проводять
своє розслідування.
Однак думки представників інших політичних сил у Верховній Раді розділилися.
Це тиск, це залякування, це намагання отримати
більший контроль над містом і максимально послабити потенційних опонентів.
Виглядає так, що це більш політична справа, ніж по реальних кейсах.
І дуже прикро, що мичуємо чутки, і я навіть не хочу сказати,
що це може правдою, про те, що очільника КМДА можуть
змінити рішенням президента. Начебто це вже і протиріччя Конституції.
Моя партія ніяк не ставиться.
Безумовно, корупція може бути в мерії Києва.
Тільки я хочу нагадати, як рік тому затримувався заступник Кличка
на підозрі в хабарі 100 тисяч доларів.
Після того призначенці, наближені до офісу президента,
опинилися на ключових посадах в Києвраді,
і все закінчилося. Жодних підозр,жодного суду. Нічого.
Зараз діляться грошові потоки, і мова не йде про інтереси киян.
Стосунки між Банковою та Кличком явно переживають стадію загострення,
вважає політолог Володимир Фесенко.
Перебування одразу на двох посадах у мера Києва - унікальна ситуація
для України. Жоден мер в Україні не має таких великих повноважень,
як Кличко. Центральній владі це і раніше не подобалося.
Стало очевидним, що у Кличка склалася така коаліція
забудовників з "Євросолідарністю" Порошенка.
А партія "Слуга народу" трохи була посунута від розподілу
фінансових потоків у місцевій владі.
Можливо, це вплинуло. У комунальних підприємствах
не тільки в Києві, в усіх містах завжди є корупція.
Це просто середовище для заробляння команди мера.
Якщо виникає якась напругав стосунках між центральною владою і якимось мером,
перше, що роблять - проводять обшуки в таких комунальних підприємствах,
тому що це, висловлюючись боксерською мовою, удар нижче пояса.
Команда мера запевняє, що буде давати відсіч будь-яким політичним атакам.
Проте чи витримає Кличко цей удар?
Залежить від результатів розслідування правоохоронців.
А також від рішення Конституційного суду, який має
розглянути ще одне подання від 48 депутатів,
які хочуть отримати роз’яснення: чи може бути призначений
очільником КМДА не мер, а інший посадовець.